Friends,
this is the best country in Europe to emigrate and also
if you do not have a European passport.
This country is Estonia and is lately considered the Silicon Valley of Europe.
The capital of this country is Talia and I can already
tell you that it is a very beautiful city.
Its main attractions include cost of living,
salaries are around €1,200 and monthly expenses above €600.
Another attraction is low taxes,
although 20% of profits are paid,
companies pay 1.0.
Another important fact is that this public report
is completely free of charge for all residents.
This is also one of the most technological countries in the world.
All procedures are done completely online,
except getting married and divorced.
If you want to know how to get here,
the easiest way is a study visa,
it is between 20 and 30 days and the cost is €60.
Now I want you to tell me you will be Tony at your next destination.
Here is a much more detailed video on my YouTube channel.